[Music]
let's say this man your county's been
[ __ ] well mine it's been very our
county has been linked very well this is
just a couple days ago this is also this
is a white male between five eight and
five ten he's got brown fuzzy hair sam
roberts
a convenience store surveillance camera
caught him on video buying a drink
around one in the morning on may 2nd
minutes later deputies say he left dixie
boy travel center just off dixie boy
travel center i know that one i know
where he is i know that one that's the
one that there's a loves across the
street from that and a taco bus well no
what i'm saying is across the street
he's right gloves is that i know that
taco i know exactly where it is it's the
auburndale water tower right i know
exactly where this is oh my god i wasn't
even looking look at the water tower
it's right by the auburndale water tower
yeah that's right off i-4 it's like
literally right off i-4 they're just off
i-4 and pokes that's one of those exits
for those of you that are we're going to
go a little local here royce will agree
with me that's one of those exits where
you're when you're really low on gas
you'll like very often you'll go
let me see if i can make it past this
exit like i don't have to stop here like
you just cause the roads suck on this
exit yeah they're very inconvenient but
then also
you know there's just like taco bus and
dudes jerking off in the park boy fuel
center
i mean that enough should let you know
travel center just off i-4 in polk city
and approached a woman who was pumping
gas he walked up to her and exposed
himself
look to be fair and i'm not blaming the
woman here however you did go to a dixie
boy fuel center in auburndale that's all
i'm saying okay
she jumped in the car locked the car and
then he walked up
and rubbed himself on her rear-view
mirror
well
why is there a mushroom why is there a
mushroom imprint on your rear view it's
very weird it appears that this isn't
the only place that he's struck it's
wacky thai guy ken suarez ken suarez
loves his wacky ties yeah there's a
similar incident over in tampa the next
day more trouble i am almost 100 sure
it's the same person
we need to know who this person is
they're a deviant
and they're dangerous are they mech
dangerous investigators say a man
presumably the same one
chuck schulling slater royce
himself to a sunbather on ben t davis
beach right off the courtney campbell
causeway and groped her you're such a
weirdo
away from me
she was quick-witted enough to record
this video of him as he picked up his
belongings and walked away this guy's a
problem investigators in two counties
polk and hillsborough how horny are you
bud
are now trying to find him if there's
two victims
there's three victims if there's three
victims there's more victims well i'm
sure there's a at one point it's going
to stop yeah i mean you can't just
yeah exactly yeah if there's 99 victims
450 000 kids let's relax man which
detectives are now determined to find as
well
in polk county ken suarez fox 13 news
now if you think you know who that man
is heartland crime stoppers is offering
a three thousand dollar reward
uh jimmy fallon and beto o'rourke had a
chance yeah